elisa comienza a caminar desde un punto
a 5 km de la escuela y camina alejándose
de está a una velocidad de 3 kilómetros
por hora estaba a 5 km de la escuela y
todavía se va a ir más lejos la tabla a
continuación muestra la distancia en
kilómetros de otros estudiantes a la
escuela en varios momentos todas las
personas caminan a una velocidad
constante y todas empezaron a caminar
entre igual a cero así que estas son las
distancias que los separan de la escuela
después de una hora dos horas y tres
horas de haber estado caminando cuáles
estudiantes estaban más lejos de la
escuela que elisa cuando empezaron a
caminar
entonces esencialmente lo que quiero
hacer es descubrir cuál es su distancia
cuando t es igual a cero y compararla
con la distancia de elisa comencemos con
gordon gordon cuando han pasado dos
horas estaba a dos kilómetros de la
escuela y cuando había pasado una hora
estaba a cuatro kilómetros de la escuela
vamos a encontrar su velocidad la tasa
de cambio de la distancia con relación
al tiempo
cuando transcurre una hora
cuando transcurre una hora gordon ha
pasado de haber estado a 4 km de la
escuela a haber estado a 2 su cambio
neto en la distancia fue de -2
por lo tanto gordon se está acercando a
la escuela a una velocidad de 2
kilómetros por hora
si cuando ha pasado una hora estaba a 4
km entonces empezó a caminar a una
distancia de 6 kilómetros 6 kilómetros
de la escuela y noten que es consistente
cuando empezó a caminar estaba a 6 km de
la escuela pasa una hora y está a 4 pasa
otra hora y está a 2 y pasa otra hora y
ya llegó a la escuela así que gordon
estaba a 6 km de la escuela cuando
empezó a caminar que son más de los 5
kilómetros que separaban a elisa de la
escuela por lo tanto gordon estaban más
lejos que elisa giovani pues giovanni
cuando estaba había estado caminando por
una hora estaba a 5 km de la escuela y
después de otra hora estaba a 6 por lo
tanto giovanni tiene un cambio neto
positivo de 1
y se está alejando de la escuela a una
velocidad de un kilómetro por hora de
modo que cuando empezó a caminar debía
de haber estado a 4 km de la escuela de
este modo habría estado a 4 km y cada
hora se habría alejado un kilómetro
noten que también podría haber comparado
después de tres horas contra dos horas
hubiera dado exactamente lo mismo los
dos son cambios de un kilómetro bueno y
que dejan ganas siempre está a 5
kilómetros parece que jane está dormida
o algo así de modo que gana ni siquiera
está caminando y por lo tanto podría
asumir que cuando empezaron a caminar
todos los demás hand estaba dormida y
seguía a 5 kilómetros de la escuela por
lo tanto hannah no están más lejos de
hecho hand estaba a la misma distancia
que elisa veamos alberto alberto cuando
estaba a una hora de haber empezado a
caminar estaba a 9 km de la escuela y
después de otra hora estaba a 10.5 por
lo tanto alberto se aleja de la escuela
a una velocidad de 1.5 kilómetros por
hora eso significa que en el tiempo te
iguala 0 alberto estaba a 9
1.5 7.5 hay 7
7.5 kilómetros de la escuela que es
mayor que los 5 km de liza por lo que
alberto también estaba más lejos que
lisa la respuesta correcta es gordon y
alberto